des lycéens de saint quentin en yvelines
venu en apprendre plus sur l'entreprise
airbus defence and space sur ce site
implanté à elancourt des ingénieurs
travaillent notamment sur la
cybersécurité ou encore l'électronique
de défense
on a une nouvelle révolution
industrielle qui est devant nous qui est
l'utilisation de logiciels l'utilisation
du big data l'utilisation d'une machine
learning de l'incident sur ciel tout ça
dans de la production qu'on pourrait
imaginer pourtant classique et ça c'est
une usine du futur une industrie qui se
renouvelle et qui offre de nombreuses
opportunités d'emploi
selon la secrétaire d'état n'est ce pas
nuire une hache et 50000 emplois ne
seraient pas pourvus dans ce secteur les
français ne savent pas exactement ce
qu'est leur industrie on imagine
beaucoup comme germinal des métiers
pénibles des métiers qui paye mal des
métiers qui vont disparaître alors que
c'est tout le contraire
ce sont des métiers qui paye 20 % de
plus que l'ensemble des autres secteurs
ce sont des métiers qui sont durables ce
sont des métiers qui ont du sens les
visiteurs d'un jour ont pu découvrir les
ateliers ainsi que les équipements
électroniques spatiaux même si toutes et
tous ne se destine pas forcément à une
carrière dans cette entreprise
ils ont été impressionnés pour moi
c'était une entreprise non pas avec eux
une telle ampleur et beaucoup de monde
comme ça notre message aujourd'hui était
de leur faire comprendre que c'était
ouvert à tous que ce n'est pas forcément
que des ingénieurs qui vient de
travailler chez nous et qu'il ya de la
place pour tous les jeunes
et que les métiers scientifiques ne sont
pas si compliqué que ça la semaine de
l'industrie se poursuit jusqu'au 24 mars
avec l'ambition de susciter de nouvelles
vocations